guys I'm so excited to be back on the
road with the Jokers and you can get
tickets right now and in Practical
jokerslive.com half the cities are
announced as like 40 or 50 cities on
there and practicaljokerslive.com this
coming weekend will be in North
Charleston Charlotte Waterloo New York
and Washington DC uh in March we're in
Niagara Falls Big Show in Newark New
Jersey a home show at Prudential Center
uh Wallingford Connecticut and also the
UBS arena in Long Island we are so
psyched that's a new Arena it's
beautiful can't wait to play it later on
in March Green Bay Milwaukee Rosemont
Illinois then we move on to Seattle
Portland Boston uh Utah Denver Arlington
all a bunch of Texas a bunch of Ohio all
the dates are on there right now uh the
show is so much fun it's new it's fresh
it's 100 new material it's interactive
it's pretty crazy we do some crazy stuff
at this show you're gonna really love it
so I'm excited to be on the road I just
finished my tour this is the new one in
practicaljoyslive.com folks Joe to Rosa
here here I got some live dates coming
up gonna be in Baton Rouge on March 9th
gonna be Lafayette March 10th March 11th
New Orleans those are all in Louisiana
March 22nd I'm back at the crane theater
doing the one man show I Never Promised
You a Rose Garden that's also the show
I'll be doing on the road at all these
dates unplugging right now March 30th
Amtrak Michigan uh Grand Rapids on the
31st of March April 1st Chicago Illinois
uh Batavia Batavia Illinois I don't know
how to say it uh April 2nd and then
Columbus Ohio April 21st and 22nd and I
think we're adding a date for Stamford
Connecticut in there as well in April
all kinds of dates coming up come check
me out I want to see you out there all
tickets and show info are available at
jodarosainfo.com and come to Joey Rose's
sandwich shop and bar if you're in New
York City open seven days a week at 11
30 a.m ever every day we've got
sandwiches new old drinks all kinds of
stuff you know the deal come on out
folks all right I'll see you later taste
buds they come into the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools gonna fight
but only one food can be right taste
buds man yeah they're coming to them
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds here we go folks we got a
guest in the house today here's what I
like about this
Our Guest today it legitimately always
weighs in on these things on Instagram
when I see him he always tells me how
much he loves this show I know he has
opinions he's he's actually he's one of
the people that actually really like
what we do and know what we do so that
makes it 100 times more exciting for me
when we have a guest like that all right
that's great I didn't know Aaron Berg hi
sorry
yeah the great the great comedian
ironberg thanks and a great friend I
didn't know that you weighed in on these
things I I didn't know I was gonna love
this show the way that I love this show
now have I ever watched the full episode
no that's the answer
your name is Joe list Joe this is you
have my favorite podcast I've never
listened to an episode really yeah
because it's just Eclipse that we put up
like it's enough of people to get us a
standing with Burr
yes yes me and Bobby Kelly are smoking a
cigar doing his thing which is two
cigars two losers or whatever I saw this
this I saw I was at skank Fest yeah and
I'm one of the losers that week and so
we're smoking and then we start arguing
about food and then all of a sudden we
both get heated and I go I don't want
this to turn into any of those taste
buds and I go think it's so angry about
the food and he goes I've done it you
would get so angry and I thought that
would not happen I would not get that
angry and that's how
I started to love the show right oh
right on right on by making fun of it
not knowing what it was you don't think
you'd get angry huh well now I do that
I'm here right now that the
expectation's been built up now I kept
you waiting for 30 minutes it gets so
angry well you like you we're not
battling this today but let's put this
to the test you think egg salad see I
already know what you're trying to get
me angry you think egg salad is better
sound I've argued this is better than
tuna salad yeah what on What tuna's
gross on what planet do you think eggs
with mayonnaise are better than tuna
salad the staple say tuna they say tuna
salad with mayonnaise too though if
you're gonna say eggs with mayonnaise
tuna with mayonnaise tuna salad is is a
deli staple I mean it's a Cornerstone
sandwich maybe this is questionable
mayonnaise is questionable on its own
then you take out a chopped up fish that
was killed up to eight years ago okay
yeah listen I was directing it at him
or his canned dude Tuna fishes and it's
dry but why it's dry if you don't know
how to make it do you know how to make
it I know how to make tuna salad do you
not really no you don't no you can tell
you don't I can't I can tell you leading
the witness you're you're the kind of
guy like your wife goes away and you're
eating like taco shells out of a box as
a meal do you cook last week
and they were so good
hold on I want to be clear I don't I
don't mean you make the whole kit I mean
you just eat the shells
I cook a little bit but I just like egg
salad but I see I'm not that angry about
it I okay there yeah you like tuna salad
I like egg salad oh but that's because
we haven't really scratched a surface
like no you have you got to get into a
10 or two you guys get furious we do
well we never argued with Sal it's in
Fury no well I'll tell you what I've
never argued like I've argued on this
podcast yeah and basically my arguing is
a byproduct of his ability to reach a
certain level of anger that I mean
honestly I'm not telling you something
you don't know it's unparalleled you can
only meet that type of anger with other
anger otherwise you're done for it
you're done yeah so you're saying
if you were just happy nice Sal and be
like no you know me I agree with you
then he'd roll up many many many many
years I've never seen him never seen him
lose damn pictures
have you ever seen me
but laughing now I you're an enigma to
me I don't understand how you live your
life okay I just like all fantasize
about people's lives sometimes you're at
the top and I don't understand why not
not that I would want you a I go first
of all how's he do why is he even here I
don't understand why you're even here I
understand that you get joy from this
right but I don't understand I go how
does he do all the things he does with a
you look like you're in horrible shape
that concerns me like you don't like a
healthy guy
and I don't mean it in a bad way no no
I'll be the first you don't mean
I'm the first to say that my my schedule
is [__] the way I take care of myself is
[__] you party I'll see you you have a
couple drinks yeah but I've really
lightened that I don't know where to
stop and then here's what I wonder about
you know where to stop do I not is that
what you're saying Joe no you no I've
heard so many stories and God forbid if
my wife would have been more of a drunk
I would not have married her because Joe
DeRosa would have been in her life at
some point
is in the union for glass ceilings he
just keeps installing and breaking him
we don't know we don't know where your
level of drunk is you just keep breaking
the ceiling
maybe that was a lot maybe I took the
Hardware Route there what I'm saying is
yeah you don't have are you doing I
would have I would have hit on your wife
and David I I heard a story that it
could have almost happened did I hit on
your wife didn't hit on her but there
was a possibility there that it could
have occurred I don't think that that's
true all right I think he does lie a lot
I think we but you know but why would
she lie about it no I'm sure worst case
scenario we were probably in the same
room drunk together that's what happened
and you know someone else by all
intentions there was another human there
yeah another human that female human
okay yeah so yeah my wife
yes that's correct
we might want to remove this from the
yeah
make it sound like I'm [__] I'm
[__] encircling your wife like a
shark not like that at all
what are you doing
all right I don't just in case
but yes it is true that your wife is a
is a lovely woman lovely attractive
woman and she did like to have a few
drinks back in the day yeah as did I as
did I yeah
would you oh my God the level
the level of drunk I got at your wedding
was it drunk the next morning I had to
be on Live with Kelly Ripa at 6 30 in
the morning no you didn't I got home at
202 vomiting everywhere went to Kelly
Ripa drunk we were following Denzel
Washington that day Chris Pratt was the
guest host and I made an absolute fool
of myself on live television I bombed
Horrible no you did I swear I tell the
story on stage I need this in the new
tour I swear to meet Denzel
I didn't but I did something really bad
I'll tell you real quick real quick okay
real quick they were giving away a trip
right so it was a time that Chris Pratt
was out with the Magnificent Seven the
remake of the Hollywood cowboy movie and
Denzel was his co-star and uh I got
there at six o'clock I was drunk I had
no I had no good judgment I didn't tell
us never told us
I think maybe yeah
and I'm like these things are so
freaking boring plus I gotta follow
Denzel how do I make it a funny segment
so I ran across the street toward Duane
Reade I bought a pack of Hanes t-shirts
and a Sharpie okay and I wrote on on the
shirt myself The Magnificent Seven and
my joke was gonna be when I went out
there that Chris and Denzel need all the
help they can get with this damn movie
right so I'm just trying to I thought it
was and then I also thought it'd be
funnier to misspell everything so I
wrote the magnificon Savon okay and then
we're waiting to go out there and they
could try to give they're doing a call
or trivia with the thing right and the
lady it's for a trip and she gets it
wrong and Chris Pratt says I'll take
another shot and she gets it right and
he gives her the trip he's not allowed
to do that his legal ramification so
live on the air they tell him they take
a trip back oh so so he's he's like I
don't know what to do and he goes how
much is the trip I'll pay for it right
oh so then Kelly's like I'll pay for it
we're splitting everyone's going nuts to
when Denzel comes out he's like I was
watching from backstage how much was the
trip and he's like 5 700 bucks and
Denzel's like I'll go in three ways
so I'm in the back watching I'm still
drunk and sick from your goddamn wedding
yeah I'm wearing a t-shirt a Haynes
t-shirt to walk out to everyone else is
in suits it says the Magnificent
Savannah and Sharpie on it look there's
my
this is the day of the morning after
your wedding yeah and I go out and I go
out and I basically the first thing I do
I didn't tell him I was gonna say it and
I walk out there and I I just say excuse
me before we start the first thing I say
I go before anyone says anything I just
want to say I'm not going in on four
ways on a trip for the woman
and nobody laughing they did not laugh
nobody else Kelly actually said they the
way they cut it here isn't the full
version Kelly actually goes no don't
worry she'll still get the trip don't
worry about it yeah and I'm like oh did
they [__] take me don't take me hey
[__] serious here wow and and then
and then they made no big deal of the
shirt so I just sat there with the shirt
on the whole time so I just walked out
they must have thought I was like on a
spectrum or something yeah you know I
walk out with a misspelled t-shirt on
the movie he's on I'm like I'm not
paying for the lady you know like I just
it was just so weird and it was all
because of how drunk I got drunk at that
wedding my wife got drunk then we tried
to go back to Queens she went to stop at
the house where her family was staying
they rented a house she's banging on the
window yelled open the goddamn wrong
house
like on the 50s 50s and second or
something she's banging on the I go Han
this isn't the house and she came back
and she my wife would get like real real
you know too drunk you know that too
drunk where you're Surly
my wife gets Shirley yeah and when I
don't remember her ever getting Shirley
you're not married to her and she mixes
it up she gets Surly surely my wife my
wife costed Jude Law on the street just
walked up grabbed him by the arms she's
like we're doing a comedy show come
watch she's like no I'm good thank you
and then walk down the street oh wow
yeah is that why you you puke it all out
on stage the way you do oh yeah
go stop saying you identify as another
thing
Trump in 2025.
is it 24. I'm not a trump supporter I
know I know I stopped the last rally I
lost my wall it was horrible
I'm in terrible health I understand yes
wait wait record did you see you people
[Music]
it's okay I was happy to see friends in
it
overall the movie was just okay but but
it was it had a funny moments but my
favorite part is Schultz
Shader Schultz is the funny song yeah
it's all of Jonah Hill's drunk [__]
friends talking at the wedding yeah and
the whole movie is like all the white
people and the black people they just
don't mix right but uh it cuts the show
they don't monetize your speeches at the
wedding and it cuts to show to these
ghosts made me laugh I stormed the
capital
that's it that's the whole line
it's so funny something else but like he
totally like undercuts like it's so like
randomly cut in it's yeah it's really
funny it's really fun anyway good I'm
sure no no I'm just joking around with
him me fantasizing about your life I
don't know how you do it how you're that
busy and then I picture by the way this
I have a nice house but in my mind I
picture your house and I and I never
want to see it I live normally no not
your apartment with comic books I
picture I picture Sal's house and I and
I just love I hope it's still on Staten
Island you haven't moved I just picture
I just I just picture that house I've
been there just being the king of staff
underwhelming underwhelming
not a great location wow right right by
the bridge just cars whipping by
[Music]
the condo now but I'm moving you're in a
continental yeah he's got a nice pad
yeah nice condo all right you've never
been at the house never been there oh
come by nowhere
you should sell me your condo
when you move do you really want to buy
my condo I probably can't afford it I
don't think
but maybe I should maybe that's how I
can finally own something maybe I should
buy your condo from you
oh
God huh
but then I would live there I would have
to drive there I will tell you I just
live in Staten Island I will tell you
this oh actually when I move out the my
number one goal is to find a close
friend or family member that will live
there to just cover my nut I wouldn't
even charge you the full price because I
want someone there I want I don't want
to sell it I want to keep it and I want
someone that's going to keep good care
of it
the last thing you'd lost them on take
good care of it yeah please do it I'm
gonna be a Bordello of Blood I'm in need
for you've been in my apartment I've
been eat free uh we talked about on off
offline beep it uh I mean it's probably
going to be uh
holy Jesus Christ Joe for Staten Island
forget it my God Almighty that what well
that's what Rudy Giuliani lived
downstairs like the maintenance feels
great I couldn't afford to buy it but it
scored you got a pool you got a hot tub
tennis court how do you get home at
night this I wonder about do you take an
Uber or do you have a driver service
you're insinuating that he leaves Staten
Island it doesn't try to orchestrate
every plan in his own apartment I see
him in the city quite often yeah [__]
off Aaron I've never seen him start with
me don't start with me I've never seen
him on Snapchat he came in here you're
really sucking up to the big guy right
yeah that's great throw a little love my
way you're telling me I'm hitting on
your way he's the sidekick this guy's
got a nice house
you know yeah I got you know let's talk
about my my life a little bit pretty
good life he's got a pretty good life
you didn't think it a couple years ago
you're like he's done you're like Joe's
done dude I remember do you want to hear
the truth the truth I hope
no I'm not going to say it I just I know
a guy who's done very well for himself
that I remember at one point talking to
him at a something and and sang in my
head this poor bastard doesn't have a
shot and then now he's it's insane
Stephen can you say who it is it's
amazing how this happens
I'll tell you after I'll just tell you
after damn I really wanted yeah but I
had to I'll tell you after but I told
you my but I
you guys want to know my mortgage no I
know but this is different God forbid
this guy this you know what I mean I
know how much money my Dodge Ram costs
it's nuts I think you think that I'm uh
better off than I am I I think you're
very well off that's what I think and I
think you're doing good yeah it's too
late
I'm going on Mike Feeney's podcast
tomorrow no Wednesday yeah to talk about
that Ari shiver went on there and
unprompted for no reason just started
making up a story that I was in tax
trouble and I was gonna maybe go to
prison yeah
it's it's so funny it's hilarious it's
completely unfound that it's not true he
just made it up I texted feeding I go
what the [__] is wrong with Ari and he
goes it was he goes that propos of
nothing it came out of nowhere but yeah
I go I go what
what that's so funny
I I called Ari I said or actually said
Ari a voice note
where it was just me laughing and I was
just going and it was genuine laughter
and I was going what is wrong with you
dude that made me laugh yeah me too and
he hit me back and he's like dude it's
dude you should play into it like go on
and say that you're having problems I
was like all right I'm not gonna do that
like
but it is very good make it a reality
he stole my phone once and started
texting big Jay's girlfriend Christine
uh that's funny from my phone and said
why are you with Jay this is wrong I
meant to be with you she had to know she
did not she did not know right away
until the next morning and I didn't know
where my phone was and Big Jay was
texting me going hey dude I don't know
if you know or not Christine and I are a
thing and I woke up this is when I used
to drink and I was like what did I do
right oh [__] there were allegations
dude I uh yeah Ari has done Ari has
taken my phone and texted people some
crazy [__]
uh and the only reason I knew he did is
because I caught him like three texts in
doing it because he's like rapid firing
texting like while I'm in the bathroom
or something
he took my phone another time I have a
lock code on it now he took it and he
kept hitting the lock code so many times
that my phone shut down yeah oh for for
like 10 minutes like because it thinks
it's annoying whatever
um he
the thing that just happened with me and
Soder with the I don't well I'm talking
about it like it's [__] national news
but I texted uh on a text thread during
the when the San Francisco there's a big
San Francisco guy yes I texted on a text
thread
when they were losing the Eagles
I just started riding on a thread with
Sal and me and Dan I started going uh uh
it's a shame this team didn't come to
play today what a bunch of bums right
and dad got so mad he said if I was in
the room with you right now I'd hit you
yeah
and then Ari started side texting me and
Fanning those playing and be like keep
going just keep going yeah like he
really likes he likes chaos he likes
some nice chaos uh it's it's so funny
okay oh battle time yes
please let's do the salties with with
Aaron but we're but we're not we're on
we're all in the same team
all right that's fair up to you babe up
to you all right we start each one with
a positive chance or a negative chance
okay and the positivity one is like so
we don't get too heated and the negative
one we insult each other so we we stoke
the heat but today we're on the same
time I mean should we just do the
rematch of egg salad versus tuna babe
this is posted babe oh yeah it is posted
[__] all right all right so we're doing
something different today okay this has
never happened on this show before it's
never happened no really done we've done
episodes we've done episodes defending
one food and just said like yay or nay
yeah Twinkie
but we've never done this we've never
put a battle out to the world where
there's nobody defending one side of the
battle Yeah we are all on the same team
in this room today's battle is Jersey
Mike's versus Subway we are all team
Jersey Mikes
Subway is
garbage I said this is funny right
because I text you I'm like tell me
things you like you don't like me like I
love Jersey Mike's and he said I don't
let you say I hate Subway yeah he goes
same here and I go he goes what about
you I'm like I mean Jersey Mike's all
the way he's like you want to just but
I'm like this are we just gonna rail on
subway for an hour I guess that's what's
happening well look let's start with
let's start with you want to talk bad
tuna let's start there horrible I
wouldn't eat the tuna there yeah why
I've eaten tuna salad in my life two
times right because it looks like ooze
that turns Turtles into ninjas
[Music]
[Laughter]
I wouldn't eat it they have to flip the
tuna over when you come in with the
Scoops right you don't know how Brown
and air dried it is and then it's been
there for three my friend you like tuna
and then as he's flipping that's listed
on side work at Subway stir tuna
the tune is really bad the turkey is not
I don't think good turkey and that's
what I would go when I was a fat kid I
would get a cold cut combo there was no
other sub place that was my the subway
Club in the cold cut combo where my two
guys when I was a kid double meat double
cheese double meat double cheese six
inches tall and here's the grossest part
12 double meat double cheese yeah yeah
that's a growing boy just mayo and salt
and pepper no lettuce no tomatoes
nothing I
it was just and then if you'd
refrigerate it the Mayo would congeal oh
on the sandwich and you'd go oh what's
this is this bad and you're like ah it's
still good yeah so let's they only used
to have two breads white and whole wheat
yeah I know don't talk about is does the
bread have like Styrofoam in it or
something like that it had sugar in it
it had so much sugar in it that I think
it was the standard thing we couldn't be
called bread all right so let's let's
start there's so much negative to say so
much let's start with the Positive okay
let's start the positive okay look this
is how much I hate Subway there's just
we have a shirt of Joey roses that says
our spokesperson isn't in prison like I
I [__] hate Subway our model at Joey
Rose is with the original menu of the
original eight sandwiches that we still
sell for eight bucks a piece was I said
I want to sell sub sandwiches that are
so good at Subway prices
to to stick it to them yeah because I'm
so appalled by their business model and
what they put out there but their
business model is amazing well I'm not
using the right term but I'm just
appalled by their existence anyway
uh I've written back to customers like
that like if some a guy left a bad
review because he complained that we
didn't have enough seating
but I said any complained I came all the
way down to the Lower East Side and
there wasn't enough seating and I go I'm
so sorry what an arduous task to to make
the harrowing Journey Down to the Lower
East Side I hope you were safe the
entire time I go good news there's a
Subway down here there's always plenty
of seating yeah go over there next
whatever
the public ridiculing from the from the
from the it's just so I love it it's
just so funny that like it's not even
the customers always right he just got
on there and railed on him he's like I
take a trip all the way down there I've
replied to tons of family I love the
ridicule that's what that's what I love
everyone
You're Gonna Get Ridiculous
let's not beef this up because fans will
start going and leaving bad reviews just
so I respond I don't always respond
please do not leave bad reviews well now
you do now you're giving them the
[__] in the hopes that I will respond
no as a matter of fact actually I
checked if there's a fan of this show
that has not gone on just for the just
for the out of the goodness of your your
heart and for Joe's like to leave a good
comment yeah if you've been to the place
and you and you want to say something
nice yeah yeah and by the way most
mostly the fans have only left wonderful
children they're great sandwiches
thank you but let me say this so anyway
so so the uh guys this is a new year you
got goals and factor is here to help you
achieve each and every one of them
factor is a pre- uh pair a pre-prepared
meal service it's never Frozen it's
always fresh that gets delivered to your
door I use this service I've used it for
about six months now I absolutely love
it you go online you can choose your
meals or you can choose them for you you
can get as little as four meals or as
much as you want I also get strawberry
banana smoothies delivered to me and I
actually love the meals they're really
good and there's they're really evenly
distributed as proteins as vegetables
they fill me up they're all within like
400 and something to 600 something
calories and they heat up in two minutes
flat I swear to God I don't have to cook
I just throw it in I hit two minutes and
it's been helping me uh manage my
portions and it's been helping me eat at
at a set time and honestly I don't know
why it's so tough to do that but this is
this is working for me so too busy to
cook with Factory you skipped the
grocery store I I said all this this is
what they wanted to say I already knew
it all okay no matter your lifestyle
Factor has delicious flavor packed meals
help you live to the fullest uh keto
meals calorie smart meals vegan and
veggie meals Protein Plus options on the
menu every single week it's prepared by
chefs and dietitians each meal has all
the ingredients you need to feel
satisfied all day long and I tell you
this right now I eat it it's a
controlled portion but I actually really
do it fills me up uh this 34 Chef
prepared dietitian approved weekly
options so there's always something new
to try cut out the takeout not only is
Factor cheaper than takeout but the
meal's already in two minutes
uh head to factormeals.com
taste buds five zero and use the code
tastebuds50 to get 50 off your first box
that's code taste buds five zero at
factormeals.com
tastebuds50 to get 50 off of your first
box guys if you haven't heard us talk
about bespoke post it's really cool and
you should check it out it's basically a
service where you get a box of awesome
delivered to you each month and all the
items are hand curated from smaller
businesses and you never know what
you're gonna get but you could take a
quiz is basically what you do to get
started take a quiz at box of
awesome.com and your answers help them
to pick the right box for you they cured
it for you they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued at around
70 bucks but you only pay a fraction for
it it's kind of fun man like when I go
on the road and I come home and there's
a box and I don't know what it is it's
like a little mini crash I've gotten
stuff from this knife by a forged knife
that's made of Damascus steel I've
gotten a weekend bag these are things
that I wouldn't think to go pick up on
my own and when I got them I was like I
don't have this this is so great
um plus with each box of awesome you're
supporting small businesses ninety
percent of everything that comes in the
box of awesome is from a small or up and
coming brand it's free to sign up and
you can skip a month and you can cancel
anytime it's fun check it out get 20 off
your first monthly box on top of the
savings already when you sign up at
boxofawesome.com and enter the code
tastebuds at checkout so that's
boxofawesome.com code taste buds for 20
of your first box box of awesome.com
code taste buds the
um I oh wait I hate Subway but wait wait
we all hate Subway
but wait let's start with the positive
yes give me a point okay here's the
positive I remember when I was 12 years
old and Subway opened in my neighborhood
now it was the first time I'd ever heard
of it I'd never I had no idea what this
place was but I was a hoagie freak as a
as a I always loved Hoagies you should
get a t-shirt that says Hoagie freak for
the bar too yeah that's a good yeah yeah
and then it's like a girl twerking with
a hoagie behind it why do you always got
to make it dirty it wasn't dirty she's
just a freak for hoagies yeah uh
[Music]
so I I was excited that there was this
new weird sandwich shop uh I didn't
really know if it was a chain I didn't
know what it you know I just knew it was
this new thing in a new in a new uh
shopping center that was built and
I liked it as a kid it was unique it was
kind of goofy there was a novelty to it
they used to do that weird thing where
they would cut the triangle piece out of
the top of the bread and take it out and
put it was fun there was like a fun
thing about Subway as a kid as there is
with a lot of you know fast food places
or whatever and then you start to get
older and you start to go
uh they don't cut the triangle part and
they just cut it regular now well now
don't make it look like a regular real
sandwich
once Subway started trying to make it
look like a real sandwich was when I
started to have problems because I was
like guys that's not what we're here for
but yeah this looks like this once this
stopped looking like vending machine
food I was out I was like
well no but I actually say the other
other way around it's like it it it
doesn't really like we live in New York
man yeah we have we have delis so for us
seeing a Subway I'm just like this is
just a but you never liked it ever no no
I did it was nice
so first and foremost it was very
affordable I love the combo because I
love to and they bake the cookies quote
unquote they used to have the Otis
Spunkmeyer cookies they have cookies I
don't know if they're Otis I I actually
it was my go-to
when I go to the movies
I would go to Subway and I'd buy a 12
inch put it in my jacket pocket wow and
then I would I would eat half of it
that's one thing I like about that I'll
eat half and I saved a half for later
the other half and it comes in the bag
so I take it out of the bag I put the
other one back in the bag and it's kind
of like a one for you one for now one
for later situation they were there was
for some reason I like I like sorry
please I was just gonna say for some
reason because of their packaging
they it did it did lend itself very well
to the one a little bit now a little bit
later concept if you had to do it and it
was only because of that plastic bag
yeah I don't know why but that plastic
bag really made a difference because you
got the bag you could swing it around
you always give you enough napkins which
I love uh I like that you could I I like
being like I want this I want this I
like running through the garden that was
fun that was a fun thing I I never put
olives on my sandwich except if I'm
there yeah I I have black Peppers too
only at Subway only at Subway
um but I I will say like uh
I always tend to
no matter what you get it almost oddly
tastes the same unless you're getting
like a meatball but like no matter
whatever no matter what combination
you're getting at the end of the day if
you're putting on the oil and vinegar
and you're putting the peppers in and
and you're putting the olives and you're
putting the shredded lettuce
the meat's just stand in there you're
right you're right it's got no pop it's
a sandwich of
the dressings
or Capricorn I'll say this I'll bite
into either one of them
the meat is just standing there is so
funny Subway meat I'll say this about it
Subway meat always looks puffy and wet
always always
uh I'll tell you some [__] I don't
like give me a full slice of cheese
don't try and pass a triangle this is
what I'm saying so this is what I'm
saying when they stopped doing we're
gonna cut the triangle out of the top
and stuff our puffy meat down into the
pocket and then put these weird triangle
slices on top when they'd stopped it and
they cut the roll normal I was like guys
this doesn't work anymore with these
ingredients it only worked before
because it was it was like eating like a
[__] hot pocket that you're building
in front of me or something the cheese
they're putting it on like it's gold
there's two yes yes
what is there a tomato shortage yeah
you're so chintzy with the tomatoes but
listen Subway I will say this outside
this all day my nod to something
I will not dispatch the subway I will
nod this much to Subway if you say I
want more of that they'll put more yeah
begrudgingly but but still like you're
the [__] that's screwing up the whole
night are they the first chain though
that did that like tell me what you want
to put it on dude and there's no extra
charge right if it's not meat of cheese
I give credit where credit is due
Chipotle wouldn't wouldn't be around
without something USA okay
such a bullet could run yeah yeah really
so Chipotle could fly let's be honest
that's true but but yeah no but no P
Holmes has had the when we were much
younger communities had the funniest
joke about Subway where he was just
trashing the entire experience of how
[__] gross it was
the greatest he goes
classic peanut so there he goes this is
what they're doing in the front what are
they doing in the back
in God's name what are they doing in the
back it was something
there's a back because I've seen guys
come in and out of it really that's
where the things work my buddy Ray
worked at Subway when I was in college
and he and we would go in and he would
give us what is going on he would give
us off the because free sandwiches they
would make whatever we wanted and then
they were videotaping them and he got
fired no no
so they might have been Trailblazers in
that respect like I'll take that that
that I also absolutely despite the yoga
mat uh content of the bread I do like
that it's like choose from eight eight
big breads they lost me there too man
that was another that was another place
where they lost me it got it was too
much it was nobody needs bread that has
like cheese melted on top of it I'll
tell you like it's weird cheese on it
yeah I don't know why you're saying that
you like bread with cheese because it's
not because here's why because it's not
a hot it's dude you're not talking about
like you're going into a place and
getting a fresh break we're all with
cheese but they do did they not make
them there they bake them well they eat
them up cheese doesn't really the cheese
is kind of already on there and it's dry
yeah
but I still like my little hint of
Asiago yeah like a little ass I like
that bread with the cheese that's like
when you buy wheat bread in the store
and it says like honey wheat and you're
like it's barely tastes they're also all
in on the fountain soda which I I don't
mind they are the first place I remember
allowing for a free refill oh of a
fountain some people just hang out at
Subway all night eat eat half a sub you
sit there I'm waiting for my girlfriend
yeah for three years yeah writing your
screenplay
we should start that track where you're
people who just write in the subway all
day
it's a Starbucks of like Iowa
China called Subway homeless Hibachi oh
that's great that's funny that's great
that's perfect that's what it is
I was gonna say guys we have a lot of
we're giving it a lot of Guff but it is
insanely successful so a lot of subways
around how why is it that successful I'm
gonna tell you this when there's nothing
you got a Dunkin Donuts or Subway where
are you gonna go and you need to eat I'm
gonna go to Subway
hey buddy I got news for you I heated up
fake frittata well I'll tell you what
you you can't get into Dunkin Donuts
it's a nice sandwich
I'm gonna tell you don't like that you
don't like two hand making cheeses on a
sandwich
I don't really trust Duncan with food
yeah like I said I'll get that heated up
for today I'll also I'll also by the way
I also have to leave four Dunkin Donuts
and a black coffee and called like I
said I'm on a Steakhouse steak Donuts
and call it if you're talking meal if
you're talking wearing a pinch every
four Donuts in my life how slow would
you get after four Donuts you got sick
now your body just shuts down you can't
eat four Donuts it's not two donuts and
you feel like I've made such a bad
mistake
I regret immediately no way dude three
if I'm gonna eat donuts I have at least
three that's Insanity not at least I
should say three is my my number but
you're talking about you're three donuts
and a sit down yeah like if I get donuts
for breakfast say three for breakfast
powdered sugar jelly Boston cream what
are you going chocolate cake with the
ice not with the sprinkles no no the
chocolate cake one with the with the
clear glaze
on a Sunday you're not talking a normal
weekday
I don't do it often you a pig
I'm gonna do it how often do you eat
three Donuts I don't eat three Donuts
every few months every four times a year
you sit down with this gluttonous Buffet
Donuts so I I swear to Christ I've never
heard of any women eating four dogs
three times I don't know if I've ever
heard anyone in three no one needs three
coconuts he's talking about we're
streaming on the highway
he's remember we're streaming on a
highway and we desperately need to eat
and your meal has to be Subway or Dunkin
Donuts I might eat four Donuts if it's
dinner I don't know over the Subway
on this I'm just trying to stay on on
theme and best Subway say maybe I might
would rather go have four Donuts uh
Subway sandwiches you think are served
every minute in in the world every
minute
two thousand oh you're dude you are so
far off
you think it's higher oh I think it is
50 000. I'm gonna say seventy two
hundred
wow all right all right
50 000 you thought it was
well these he said there was 30 000
locations didn't you yeah thirty
thousand so I was like okay one a minute
I've never gotten this I've never got a
Subway sandwich in under a minute no
you're talking that's a that's a four
day oh yeah
right yeah right so I'm saying is in 30
on locations let's give one thing so I
got to thirty thousand and then I gave
it an election I'm saying and what I'm
saying is is I've never gotten a Subway
sandwich in a minute or less yeah let
alone seeing a place churn out two in a
minute to get it up multiple workers
Jersey Mike's to to an Accolade to who
we all love Jersey Mike's I've seen
Jersey Mike's make a sandwich faster
than Subway and they're slices
I think Jersey Mike's is terrific I
think they they're that is a a chain uh
that that doesn't like it feels like a
deli it's a chain that feels like it's
so good uh I'll tell you I'll tell you
not to throw this into the mix but I'll
tell you who also has banging sandwiches
and it's it's under everyone's radar and
people in the west don't even know about
it but it definitely beats Subway Wawa
dude
is always fresh I like the one buddy
you're talking I know I mean it's I grew
up with it I mean I grew up literally I
used to ride my bike to Wawa and then
over to the newsstand to look at the by
the way double meat and double cheese at
Jersey Mike's it like it's like a New
York Deli double meat it's massive yeah
dude the large New York sub or sorry the
large Jersey Mike's Sub is like 16
inches yeah because you can get yeah
there's like different sizes it's like
way bigger right I will say this Jersey
Mike's does get a little pricey it does
get a low price Jersey Mike's on
seamless the other day my I had roast
beef
turkey provolone I did the double meat I
do always get bacon on that no all right
sandwich but I get baked really gotta be
in the mood
1749 for that sandwich yeah I've done it
seven and that's before tax I've done it
I get the I get the one that's like the
Italian Meats that's what I sell my
house Subway's still like you can still
get a sandwich for like four dollars
I'll tell you who's beating everybody
when it comes to Meats
like meat weight and and do it for your
buck tell me who's beating everyone when
it comes to meat weight
he's dropping gems today man
I'll tell you what and I don't like them
more than Jersey Mike's but I do like
them Jimmy John's I will tell you Jimmy
John's is is a Jimmy John says it's in
the same class yeah and Jimmy John's has
a new sub called the Italian nightclub
and it's cocaine that's funny that's so
funny really funny sure it's really
funny yeah absolute vodka oil and it's
uh it's like it's recorded I swear to
God I swear to God I didn't get that
they made hit it with the act like
nightclub like dance club when I got it
that was like yeah and I was like
why are they calling it a club sandwich
it doesn't have bacon or anything like I
was so I thought they would still be
bacon in it as well no it's just an
Italian sub basically but it's a new
it's a new company don't put bacon in it
no so it's just why is it the Italian
nightclub just to be make fun of
Italians I think but it's Italian
nightclub's a thing sure I don't know
but here's the point an Italian
nightclub oh yeah yeah like like oh like
you know like it's like Saturday Night
Fever sure sure in any case it's an
awesome combo
bacon in it I I don't know okay it's a
shame I don't know what you would say if
you were Italian and you got it you'd be
like this is a shame right that's what
you'd say I wouldn't like that throw it
in your face okay but anyway
I got that in in Austin I went to a
Jimmy John's I was like was craving it
Texas yeah I just I saw it I was hungry
I was like I'm gonna get Jimmy John's I
got this new Italian nightclub I got
double meat dude I think I paid
I think it was under 15.
under 15 for doubling it was 15 but dude
excuse me
here's the difference he's still burping
it up sorry here's the difference I've
gotten Jersey Mike's with the double
meat
I eat the whole sandwich yeah I'm like
uh this is I'm climbing Everest right
now like this is this is a substantial
sandwich I'm eating okay now like
substantial like now I'm not saying that
makes Jimmy John's better
I'm just saying like when it comes to
bang for your buck I don't know that and
and then also a quality sandwich I don't
know that anybody's messing I'll tell
you one thing if I if we're being fair I
gotta send the critique to Jersey Mike's
uh I get my sandwiches uh instead of oil
and vinegar salt and pepper I just do
red wine vinegar and pepper I keep the
salt in the oil yeah I got that sandwich
man that sandwich was soggy wow yeah it
happened so put it in between the meat
you can't let do me a favor don't put it
right into the system this is what I've
learned as a fan of sandwiches in my
whole life
it's not that you cannot let another
person put vinegar on your sandwich you
can't do it they don't know the ratio is
off more than it's on vinegar is very
very vinegar is very case-to-case person
yes olive oil or oil I mean everybody
always knows a little bit that's all
Mayo worst case scenario you open it up
you scrape some off whatever or you
don't get enough vinegar
people I can't tell you once you go too
much you can't go back that's it and
then the spine of the sandwich gets the
red because the vinegar's soaking
through you can especially on delivery
dude I've told a guy making a sandwich
when he puts dude I'm sorry you got to
start over that's too much come on no I
wouldn't have to I wouldn't go to Jersey
Mike's I wouldn't have the balls to do
that Jersey Mike's once in a jersey I
would be like I wasn't rude I would say
I'll pay for it I wasn't rude I wasn't
like demanding that's too much that's
too that's dude it's too much really I
just wanted a little because I said
first I did in my defense I said a
little bit of vinegar and he went nuts
and I was like dude oh that's annoying
and he's like all right sorry and he he
got it he wasn't I I wasn't as I didn't
say it as shitty oh no Mike's way you
won't go Mike's way I won't allow a man
to do to give me Mike's way really not
even Mike himself wow I gotta say
Subways
um one of their taglines was eat fresh
yep and I don't get that from them when
I eat it but I will say one of the
things I note about Jersey Mike's is it
feels very fresh the bread feels very
fresh is it baked on premise I couldn't
speak to that cell but I'd like to know
like to find that out I also like about
Jersey Mike's little known fact they
started in Jersey that's correct oh did
they yep
the first place I ever sold Jersey Rex
was La yeah and I was like I think they
just called it that dude so you would
feel like it was the first the first 50
times I had Jersey Mike's was in Point
Pleasant New Jersey yeah yeah I didn't
know little little Shack right on the
right on the [__] beach right there
yeah now one defensive of subways it's
actually 10 years younger as a brand
than Jersey Mike's no way how's that
possible since 1956. but that's when
that one shop opened was there a one
Subway sandwich shop theirs would be
like 1965 they're like wait a second 65
Jersey Mike's I didn't even take off
until I I started noticing them in my
shops yeah so Jersey Mike's for that
long was just a little shop and then
when did it start to expand in like the
90s
the same the same 1950 shop though is
operating right now in Point Pleasant
yeah you know I haven't gone I've seen
the sign whenever I drive into point
plus and I see the sign yeah we should
road trip to the original Jersey Mike's
okay yeah that's fun next time you do
Joey Tomatoes yeah what's the don't they
have a isn't Point Pleasant Joey
Tomatoes
no the comedy club in Point Pleasant
is it Uncle Ben sorry they have a
pizzeria it's a great Club
Joey tomato I was booked there really it
was booked here years ago yeah and uh
those slices a big pandemic happen the
gig never happened and I go listen man I
don't really feel like driving back and
forth I'm just gonna get a hotel down
there he goes you don't want to do that
so what'd you do I it got canceled
because it was literally the next week
they were like we uh we think everybody
guys you should probably shut everything
down because
I heard about that thing it was on the
news yeah I love that they got Danny
DeVito a native New jerseyan yes uh is
that what they called The Jersey Eye I
don't know I don't know but yeah that's
I mean he's I mean he's perfect and he
does look as a man he does look like a
man that actually does eat the Jersey
believe it yeah like you talk about
spokespeople though I honestly feel bad
for Subway why they gotta they got a raw
deal with that guy yeah Jared yeah oh
yeah yeah oh that was a bad move yeah
not a good guy yeah no they didn't know
what he was doing and yes I know I look
like Jared from Subway please hold your
comment yes I've heard it for 20 years
thank you did you ever have that you
never did that as an opener every day
somebody's like I didn't know Jared from
Subway God oh dude
for 20 years
Joe Rogan from wish.com
[Laughter]
you know what pissed me off about your
guys successful the exact same thing I
do and now no matter how successful I
get I'm the poor him you'll never get
that success I know not even half
possibly not even 10 possibly not even
five percent possibly no possibly I'm
on percent
that's as good as it that's horrible
horrible to me uh don't I wouldn't I
wouldn't worry about that why you're
gonna be fine
it's not gonna I used to worry about
that with Paul Giamatti because people
should say I look like Paul Giamatti
what I see that I looked a lot more like
him when I was even in worse shape yeah
uh and I and there was like and then
because it was when American Splendor
came out and everybody was like that's
you wasn't he a curmudgeon in that yeah
that has something to do with it as well
yeah I no that's that was they were like
dude it's you in the movie right that's
you poor was like DeRosa it's you dude
and I was like [__] you man because I
hadn't seen it and then I turned it or I
finally watched it and in the first
scene the kid uh the lady goes what are
you supposed to be what's for Halloween
he goes I'm just dressed as myself I
repeat card she goes well that doesn't
make any sense and he stops off the
porch and he goes why is everybody gonna
be so stupid I was like oh Jesus
anyway
um well I was gonna say so I'll tell you
one thing I dislike about Jared prior to
all the other stuff that came out it's
not
it's misleading to hold your denim up
yeah uh in front of you from by pinching
it and holding it in tan right it looks
insanely more dramatic than it is
because if you held your jeans up in
front of you right now the ones you were
wearing you'd be half the size of those
jeans come on yeah because it's not
considering the the width of you so it's
taking the waistline and going straight
across right so yeah I know he's wearing
them there
that is that is I I don't think that
that's not the part you should be mad at
that is I think accurate but he's in
those but whenever he does it when he's
holding it in front of him and they look
like three of him sure that's misleading
but it's misleading here's the thing
here's the thing this is what bothersome
he he had uh training AIDS like he had
like physical like like uh uh trainers
yeah he did like oh he did like a
fitness regimen along with it and they
made it they made it sound as if he just
ate the scene I thought he did this in
his life and then he went to them and
said you know what I did and they were
like what no no no no no he had fun
people help him oh he was like on heat
in contract when he was doing the weight
loss he I think he did reach out because
he said he just all he did was walk
there and walk home every day he would
he did lose initial weight and then he
reached out and thinking but he did
South Park did a whole episode about it
where the joke was
the joke was they kept being like you
can't lose that much weight eating
Hoagies this is crazy this guy's on an
old Hoagie diet and then the joke on
South Park was they kept going no he has
AIDS that's why he's so skinny because
he has AIDS because he had training yeah
uh and that was the joke like you can't
lose weight doing that but people
thought for a while they're like oh
Subway's a healthy alternative yeah no
one confuses Jersey Mike's they just go
that's a good sandwich at Jersey Mike's
no one goes I'm going to Jersey Mike's
to get in shape right it's a good
sandwich and you know what be what you
are and yeah yeah but I'll say this
about Jersey Mike's
for what it is it's clean food
it's not like I'm not eating that lunch
meat going oh my God this is like you
mean like your beloved spam well that's
that was last episode but you know but
my kind of comment sticks with you I I
said that I thought it was fascinating
that you could buy a can of ham and eat
it out of it no what was no no what was
the quote
the quote was not it was very very it
was no no it wasn't even that buddy it
was very
[Laughter]
that's insane that's insane do you see
the difference between what you thought
you said and what you said
you called it a religious experience
spam all right fair enough
I find spam to be a blessing
I do I don't know what to say but I all
right it's nutty wordy but but is he in
jail for ever now
those are not good things to do
and by the way if you're gonna do them
maybe you don't brag to one of the kids
moms at the game like Jesus shared
Christ
left in jail where's he serving his time
you want to talk about you want to talk
about a textbook case of solitary
confinement out of protection of the
prisoner
he's it if there ever was in New Jersey
he's it he's it if there ever was one oh
where they lock him up alone they have
to dude like like pedophiles
get attacked and raped and very frowned
but that's like they're they're like
targeted yeah like they're targeted like
they're they're going to teach you a
lesson when you get in and he's just
he's a pedophile and a celebrity they
got that guy in a [__] Tower
somewhere the irony here is he's gonna
come out of prison ripped in better
shape than he's ever been in his life
again
he might be a little depressed yeah well
if I was him I would just
yeah who's reporting that
but but
this is what we just what I was going to
say real quick about Jersey Mike's
for what it is you know I'm not like
this is this is like it's it seems like
a quality cold cut it doesn't seem like
like way over processed or or loaded
with sodium it seems like a decent like
when I eat it I'm like look obviously I
know a a sandwich filled with cure to
Thai Meats is that a healthy thing to
eat but I don't feel bad about myself
after right I don't feel bad you just
feel like you ate a sandwich from a deli
yeah yeah like there's yeah I feel like
it's like going somebody doesn't feel
like a deli Jersey Mike's is a deli I'm
gonna tell you what else Subway did
where they messed up Diversified far too
much I get you want to have breakfast
but then what else is on their menu now
salads their salads garbage the salad is
just a sandwich without the bread yes in
a plastic thing right and they've
they've got more stuff there now like
they'll do a Falafel sub they do way too
much somebody tries to do too much and
it's really bad yeah Glazer today in
Union Square real quick aside and she
walked up the street and I'm doing man
on the street and she goes oh Aaron
Burke and then just kept walking I go
that's exactly what you're supposed to
say which is not at all shocked that I'm
doing something weird on the street
that's so funny I love Nikki Glaser uh
no Nikki's great and I'm not talking out
of school here because she's talked
about it on her radio show
like you know her older okay yeah but uh
when we were uh involved uh wait what we
would we would we would
which he drank we would get [__]
whacked like blacked out trying together
and we would go when and I we would we
we definitely hit a Subway once or she
was the only person I ever knew that got
the salad from Subway it was before they
had the salad
so she would she would just get she was
ordering off menu she was going off menu
she was like she was like give me she
would just go I just want all the
toppings like in a bowl wow
and they would make like a salad for her
and she would just pay like the sandwich
money old move yeah right yeah
they might have had the salads I might
be talking out of my ass a little bit
but I don't think they had it yet I
think she went rogue at Subway I want to
think that that's what it was did you
have a TV show at this point or pre-tv
show dude she was dating me she had
nothing
I can't eat bread I gotta do better than
this yeah she had nothing I was the name
wow
God Almighty I could write a I should
write a book about all the people that
have blown past me in this business it's
just chapter one Dan Soder yeah chapter
two Mark Norman chapter three Sam
Morrell
[Laughter]
I'm holding my footing on that one yeah
uh no man Kevin Hart Kevin Hart no I
know Kevin was already was already doing
things when I started out Kevin was
already the Kevin was already kind of
legendary in Philly he and Jay
head started at the laugh house with
Metzger and then they all left Philly
went to New York and by the time I
started doing open mics at the laugh
house in Philly they were already like
you know Kevin Kevin got a sitcom really
it's already a guy they were kind of
whispering about it's weird that I
thought he wasn't even very tight with
Jay
yeah they they used to like drive to
open yeah yeah like they they all
started they would drive Kevin couldn't
reach the pedals
I mean you don't have much I'm taller
than him how tall is he I don't know you
think he talks to me
thank you
I gotta say Kevin's always I never knew
him very well we just had like the
Philly connection yeah but he's always
been very nice to me and like I know him
enough to like say hi to him and stuff
like still a cop he's a nice guy yeah
still a comic you talked to him yeah
what way taller no that can't be right
yeah that's right that can't be right
yeah he's short he's short that but that
really great shape
he's probably five two wow he's pretty
sure I used to say I'm five seven I know
I'm not five seven I think maybe five
six but now realistically I'm five five
six four my wife's four two
uh let's go to the phones Aaron this is
when when uh we hear comments from the
listeners okay all right sorry yeah by
the way should I get Jersey Mike's
tonight yeah you should I I sure I
shouldn't yeah because I'm trying to
lose
no I might go by your place before I go
home you should yeah look at this guy
you have a gourmet sandwich shop no it's
not Court don't ever call I heard
there's a new sandwich it's it's it's
it's it's it's kind sandwich is done the
best way possible thank you very much
but why would you go to Jersey Mike's
then it's still nice you know you're
gonna pay for product
I like getting a sandwich made by
another person from a different freak
yeah I like Hoagies of all walks yeah
you know what I mean I I like them from
all over I I it's also I can get my
sandwiches anytime like it's like it's
kind of lackluster too okay I really
want one of those sandwiches go you go
through have fun you should start
drinking again we have a good day
one day you speak of me you are every
time I see you you are just in the best
shape ever and actually have a nice
Golden Bronze on you come on yes in the
summer when you do shirts when you do uh
when you do shows with like basketball
jerseys I used to wear I could never do
that I have to wear tank tops on stage
yeah I remember that you were big into
suspenders for a while
not suspect I I know I would do the vest
and the dress shirt yes yes and the joke
was like I looked like I went shopping
at a Build-A-Bear that was yeah Jay
jayerson said you look like a teddy bear
lawyer have you been a lawyer
in his defense your honor he was under
the bridge because he had to tell
riddles
very I missed that I should dress
classier I dress very you guys wear
pants look at this I wear 50. I wear it
I'm a big fan of a plaid pant these days
at night time I got it I love a plaid
pan I'm I'm not
I thought you were intimidating why not
because of not imposing in a physical
way but even though you are just I don't
know you had an aura that I was like I
don't know if this guy is gonna be like
a ball buster yeah and like dig into me
because I didn't know you at first but
then I immediately I met you and
immediately I was like oh you're such a
sweetheart you know thank you and we
became friends right away but like I I
was I think I even told you that in the
beginning if I could go back
God man it's really bad a cigar yeah you
had the tank top on you know you're
walking outside to stand back and forth
like a lion and all and this is bringing
me to this place that I keep going to
mentally because you were such a part of
it if I could go back to one period in
my life and lately it's just been this
it would be the run of the original
Stand yeah like those nights in there I
had so many memories in that place like
I had my birthday roast in there and
like we just remember that yeah just
like sitting in there doing your set
going upstairs everybody drank still
nobody was sober yet we were all young
enough to not give a [__] go into it
didn't hurt the Maguires was next door
oh the best Dive Bar in New York Patty
McGuire's going in there
right it was just you know everybody was
single or it was just a part oh God man
I missed that I lived like four blocks
from that place yeah what a time man
anyway anyway I got a piece of the Old
Stage actually oh that's very cool it's
not mine what do you mean it's Ari's not
even he has no storage so I've been
holding it for him but I'm thinking
about like it's been years now and I'm
pretty much just like not telling them
and just keeping it please will you
videotape me peeing on it please and
send it to Ari okay okay okay I was
gonna be like immediately of course but
I I want no retaliation from that you
don't need any why would you get
retaliated well I I'm the one who
because he video gave you access to it
it's my retaliation he's going publicly
and telling people that I'm in tax
trouble
because I don't I don't want the
retaliation that comes with it you can
you can take it from my home when I
don't know
if you can get it past me how big you
could do it it's in a box it's like it's
like the size of like a suitcase not
small not not thin thin like it's like
you know like this all right I'll take
it to my house and pee on it no no I'm
not letting you take it
where it is and if you can get past me
and and trick me good for you okay I
really want no I want no
repercussion I don't want to be involved
say hey off the air because I'm totally
interested in taking totally interested
in taking your place when you move I
think I can cover the knot let me come
by and take another look at it real
quick and then you take the look and
then you just leave with the thing yeah
that's all I do you didn't hear that all
right here we go to the phones pimp all
right Subway's the Little Caesars of sub
places absolutely what a great call
Jersey Mike's because I worked at Subway
and it's disgusting yeah but he's saying
they don't clean backstage
30 000 Subways I mean 27. turning up 50
000 sandwiches a minute
when did I ever shot that by I overshot
that by one thousand percent yeah if you
still eat Subway you deserve whatever
disease you get
off eat fresh
uh Subway's the armpit of sandwich shops
wow good point let me let me say one
thing though what about that jingle
though they did damage with that jingle
what was it five
five dollar
Five Dollar Foot it was a cool thing
they did that was a cool thing they did
when they had it every day was a
different five dollars everybody knew
that yeah that was when they just it's
not all it's not just all the best that
was the height of Subway yeah that was
yeah that was when they were still in
the game that's a funny thing the height
of Subway Yeah by Nature Subway is below
ground anything negative because it's a
submarine sandwich right that's why they
call it Subway submarine yes
and then just a lot of attacking the the
Jared charges all right yeah you got to
take Jared out of it yeah some people
one person said their bucket list is to
go to Joey roses thank you please come
I mean that's a real bucket list thing
they should reach they should have a
great I know that is sad I mean they
should have greater experience really
good but there's like yeah two words
Iceland yeah really like like before I
die life is you know life is fast before
I die
one day I ate all eight of them I had
eight sent to the old place and I I
didn't mean not every bite of it I had
at least half when you put those
platters out yeah I had a friend sitting
one time he was dead serious he goes if
I ever won a lottery I already kitkats
all day long
I was like you could do that right this
second it's so weird it's such a weird
thing to say they had they had your
sandwiches set up at the Stan's
Christmas party downstairs I don't know
if you know this or not they did yeah or
the 10-year anniversary sorry oh yeah
yeah
and there was Lobster upstairs so me and
Rich Voss are just pounded Lobster just
like two guys that couldn't get in the
car Lobster and we ate so much and then
I went downstairs and they hadn't put
your sandwiches out yet so they go
and I just open them and start eating
them right by the thing and I eat two
and someone comes in some staff member
they go what are you doing and I go this
is Sam they're like we haven't put them
out yet I'm like and I just kept eating
them if they're not out yet how am I
eating them yeah that's what I would
have said that's it yeah
uh give us two more pimp and then we're
saying uh they put the Subway meatball
sub against any food from any fast food
that's the stupidest thing that's ever
been tweeted to us and we've had a lot
of stupid [__] tweets that's the
stupidest thing I want to give that the
wind just for how stupid it is where do
they live there's not a lot of options
where they live trash island they're
Canadian oh well that explains there's
not a lot of opportunity to be a country
with less food options than Canada I
can't think of what do they got the
[__] gravy fries that they're always
talking about I'm going to tell you this
I think Canada does not have a lot of
good food clams they do clams but native
to them you mean yeah because there's
great restaurants in Toronto bro
you know you're gonna find a few great
restaurants
yeah and I'm from there a lot of beef
jerky uh yeah it's it's very
disappointing that they would think that
they're probably still waiting for the
McRib to come back these people that's
that's the meatball sub I bought a
Kennedy from Toronto oh I love Toronto
so much I'm going to Vancouver I really
love it it was great I love it as well
I'm only going for one day though you're
gonna fall in love with you three to
five
one day I I get in late Friday night my
Show's Saturday I leave Sunday morning
yeah but Vancouver to me it doesn't have
a Toronto Toronto has a Montreal field
but Vancouver is of its own Vancouver
doesn't have a Toronto feel at all
like no it's Pacific Northwest field you
know obviously beautiful mountains ocean
skiing yeah that kind of fun well maybe
I'll go back when I have some more time
there's a lot of heroin I took a
seaplane out to the outside out to the
snow-capped mountains yeah and I and I
swam in an empty Lake like there in
freezing temperatures it was amazing all
right yeah you're gonna love Vancouver
I'm not going to see any of it you got
it I will say this so I went there for a
vacation for three or four nights I fell
in love with the city I went back on
tour I had two shows at this theater by
far maybe tied but by far they were the
worst two crowds I had and it's like a
70 City Tour very politically correct no
no they were they were drunk ass and and
not for all not for the people that
weren't but people I'll tell you how bad
it was so many people from that show
were writing me in the days after
apologizing saying please don't judge us
by what happened oh wow yeah it sounds
like drunk animals people got excited
The Jokers were coming and no me they
partied just me Sal solo oh well it's
you know it's they're excited you're
coming and you know they go oh no dude
that's why not just come have a good
time
it's gonna be great people get too amped
up it was like no but it was like you're
talking about a [__] [__] country
that thinks the Subway meatball sub is
decent food they don't get a lot of
flash up there you know when you got
someone that's bombed and they got to be
escorted out or they're heckling and
there's a problem yeah it was it was
multiple people all 60 70 minutes for
both shows look I'll just I'll just I
just couldn't even get to the gym I went
on the outskirts of Vancouver
I don't know in Vancouver I'll just say
this to you all right you're talking
about a country who it is little as 10
years ago honored lover boy at their
music awards not a lot going on okay
okay all right
words last tiger who's what's class
tiger that one hit wonder right oh okay
I love Canada I'm joking around I'm
joking candid I love you can't justify
everything I think it was one of my
favorite cities I just couldn't believe
these people that came out to the show
all right pip one more and then let's
get the vote here a few people are
really angry that it's close apparently
uh Jersey Mike's because I want my meat
on bread not a donut there's too much
sugar in Subway's bread
Subway's a bigger chain right way bigger
yeah yeah sure that's why Mike's will
get there all right let's just real
quick aside Firehouse Subs ever heard of
it yeah it's it's okay no never heard it
they're okay
they're not here well it's yours they're
in like oh okay they well they're coming
up then they should only be in like in
Atlanta what's what's the what's the
what's I don't know I've never been
there okay they're okay I think it's an
old firefighter that's it's a decent
it's a decent sandwiches
the subway cookies is why they're going
somewhere yeah that's what I mentioned
it's a you know all right what do we got
pimp give us the percentage they don't I
will say though they need to something
besides that little plastic case on the
counter
don't put them in that
it's it's it's sad you know it's sad
Subway is sad every Subway has a
distinction yeah every Subway yeah yeah
every Subway smells exactly the same
yeah which is weird
he's comprised of the same things it's
weird that every store has the exact
same smell as soon as you walk into it
like there could be like a Subway column
you could say you could say with
McDonald's right
you could have a Subway close you could
say what McDonald's like oh when you
walk in it you'll smell the fries yeah
like that's a McDonald's smell I don't I
think McDonald's smells the same
everywhere too you you no I closed my
eyes I smell my cows because but I'm
saying you go that's the fry like the
fries have a you know what I mean what a
Subway would give that like Burger Kings
don't all smell the same you know what I
mean like in our every Arby's I've been
to doesn't smell like every other RV
like it's it's just weird that it Subway
has an absolute it's hell it's like how
every doctor's office smells exactly the
same when you add into it it's so
distinct I find it odd we don't know
what it is and I forgot this Subway
major product placement in a motion
picture name that motion picture
Wayne's World
well I mean that's very broad what
you're saying
yeah what movie is it
Coneheads Coneheads
and Happy Gilmore
oh yeah hell yeah yeah
all right pip give us the numbers let's
wrap this up the loser with with 39 Oh
that's not close the same exact as last
week's Subway
oh wow okay I honestly thought that they
were gonna give a run for our money here
because they're such a bigger chain
plug
[Music]
you got Jersey Mike's right all right uh
aaronberg.com all my tour dates I'm
coming to your city I'm going up to
Canada and brand new special coming out
April 15th on YouTube called 180. look
for it awesome congrats buddy congrats
all right well it's great to have you
buddy thanks great to have you been come
true we'll see you next time
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
they're coming to the